é um prazer tá aqui e esse é um ted
sobre Florescer né estamos o nosso
terceiro dia de evento finalmente
Chegamos na estação do inverno e nada
melhor para Celebrar o Florescer em meio
à adversidade do que falar de promover
mudanças no setor público um lugar cheio
de desafios e cheio de oportunidades
também e esse é um pouco também do meu
próprio florecer profissional e pessoal
um pouco do meu propósito de vida
e eu acredito é que políticas públicas
baseadas em conhecimento são a real
forma de transformar o governo e vou
explicar um pouco porque
e é para começar a gente quanto que
custa atualmente errar no governo é isso
a última pesquisa o bid banco
interamericano de desenvolvimento ele
estimou que o Brasil ele perde
anualmente e 60 milhões de reais de
dólares na verdade 70 milhões de dólares
ou seja quatro porcento praticamente do
seu PIB em políticas públicas
ineficientes somando aí um desperdício
em compras públicas salários é que às
vezes são excessivos dentre outras
transferências e assim por si só esse
dados da choca Mas já deveria trocar mas
por que que isso é tão grave
primeiramente porque nós estamos em um
país desigual em um país que em que
várias necessidades populares não são
demanda não são resolvidas E também o
país com recursos limitados assim como
todos os outros e nesse cenário é
importante que gestores públicos e
pessoas que atuam dentro de governos
consigam fazer a melhor em locação
os nossos recursos é mas não é tão fácil
assim né esse sistema que rege o gasto
público ele é um sistema complexo é um
sistema movido a interesses a incentivos
a Recompensas Então como que a gente
pode transformar a maneira como o estado
alocar os recursos Tudo começa com é um
conceito muito importante que é o
conceito que move a ação do governo
conselho de políticas públicas que são
políticas públicas políticas públicas e
elas são basicamente a produção do
governo em resposta ou em proposta as
demandas da sociedade elas são a forma
que o governo tem de atuar na sociedade
mais uma grande pergunta por trás de
cada política pública é quem ganha o quê
Porque e Que diferença faz quem está
sendo público alvo dessa política
pública e que realidade que ela tá
mudando
e existem existe um mar de necessidades
públicas pessoas que precisam de
Saneamento de Educação de saúde nem
todas essas necessidades elas entram na
esfera de agenda o que a gente chama de
agenda pública que aonde que o governo
prioriza as suas atividades a partir do
momento que essa necessidade foi vista
como importante e ela passa entre a
integrar a agenda pública começa o ciclo
da formulação da implementação e da
avaliação das políticas públicas e
dentro desse ciclo complexo existem as
avaliações as estatísticas que são
aquilo que permite às políticas públicas
tem um passado um presente e um futuro e
é exatamente aqui onde eu me reconheci e
me encontrei para atuar dentro do
governo
é a minha trajetória se meta do setor
público dentro do governo entender o que
é o governo começou a se materializar
para mim quando eu tinha 11 anos de
idade e com essa mulher a com do Nestor
as ela era a ministra do governo Bush
nos Estados Unidos e ela foi a primeira
mulher negra a ocupar esta posição
quando eu me enxerguei nela eu vi que eu
acho que seria eu me enxerguei como
capaz de ocupar um lugar desses para ser
uma voz ativa em meio as transformações
do mundo e para poder ocupar um espaço
de melhoria da vida das pessoas eu
estudei Entrei numa universidade comecei
a cursar administração pública me formei
e enfim com 22 23 anos de idade eu
ingressei no governo seja entusiasmo
para poder fazer o que eu sempre sonhei
e quando eu cheguei lá a
primeira-secretaria na qual eu fui
alocada foi a Secretaria de Educação do
meu estado é uma secretaria complexa
cheia de desafios cheio de oportunidades
também e a uma das primeiras coisas que
eu observei que eu aprendi foi como que
o governo toma decisão eu logo fui
alocada para um setor que cuidava e
cuida da análise de dados para poder
subsidiar as tomadas de decisão o que eu
percebi foi que muitas vezes os dados
que a gente precisa para poder tomar
decisão o governo não estão ao nosso
dispor por uma questão de organização e
sistemas de inteligência e também muitas
vezes as políticas públicas passam por
descontinuidades a cada quatro anos nós
temos uma troca no Poder Executivo que
faz com que as políticas e ações que
estavam sendo executadas anteriormente
muitas vezes sejam interrompidas e
substituídas por outras muitas vezes
semelhantes e que talvez poderiam ter
sido melhor aproveitado
é resgatado conhecimento que já tinha
ficado no passado né e isso me gerou uma
inquietude muito grande e foi aí que eu
descobri qual que seria a minha missão é
uma eu ilustrei aqui o como que eu
percebi a tomada de decisão no governo
tinha dados experiências passadas tinha
conversas e reuniões mas a grande
maioria eram vozes na minha mente era
basicamente o que que eu tô sentindo no
momento eu acho que a gente tem que
fazer isso tudo por conta dessa em
disponibilidade de informações e de
dados em tempo hábil para que a gente
possa decidir
e é diante de tudo isso eu percebi qual
que seria a minha efetiva missão aonde
que o que eu conseguiria entrar com
maior impacto né e contribuindo mais
para mim atuação dentro do governo seria
um único conhecimento evidências e
experiências os tomadores de decisão do
governo para que a gente começa a ter
políticas públicas mais efetivas e
diminuir aqueles aqueles Bilhões de
Dólares que a gente desperdiçam hoje é
em políticas públicas ineficientes nessa
trajetória já fazem 3 anos eu tive
algumas alguns aprendizados e felizmente
trouxe eles aqui para compartilhar um
pouco com vocês é primeiramente a
primeira demanda que foi trazida até mim
quando eu entrei no governo foi para que
eu pudesse avaliar uma política que
visava combater o abandono escolar hoje
em dia aí vazão escolar que são jovens
que deixam a escola né antes de
terminarem os estudos é um grande pro
a estação pública e tinha-se feito na
época uma campanha publicitária era uma
ação uma campanha publicitária que
visava conscientes ao jovem para que ele
voltasse para escola e ela era celebrada
como muito bem sucedida como enfim como
uma política que que tinha dado muito
certo porque ela tinha feito as
matrículas aumentar em Só que nunca se
tinha feito um estudo a respeito dela
para ver se isso tinha acontecido de
fato como a gente foi olhar de perto
esses dados a gente descobriu que
naquele ano existiam cerca de 60 mil
jovens fora da escola no nosso estado na
nossa rede desses apenas 316 tinham sido
impactados por essa campanha que
aparentemente não era tão bem sucedido
assim e desses 316 apenas 63 tinham
voltado a estudar de verdade essa quando
a gente chegou essa análise chegamos
essas conclusões a gente descobriu que
uma polícia que estava sendo reproduzida
amo
eu estava tendo muito pouca efetividade
Isso foi um choque isso nem sempre é tão
bem visto né dados muitas vezes advogam
contra política quando políticas
públicas que os gestores querem
implementar e muitas vezes as evidências
não são bem vistas não são vistos com
bons olhos por isso que é um trabalho é
um trabalho que você tem que fazer com
muito cuidado mas com muita com muito
compromisso e com muita responsabilidade
porque eu acho que o papel do Servidor
Público o papel de quem atua no governo
é apontar a realidade para que as
pessoas que estão na tomada de decisão
posso escolher como elas vão representar
ou não a sociedade o próximo aprendizado
que eu tive foi um dilema muito famoso
entre da exaustividade versus a
tempestividade esse dilema é consiste em
muitas vezes é Eu por exemplo várias
pessoas querem fazer as demandas análise
de dados estudos da melhor forma
possível trazendo
Há muitos indicadores mas se isso demora
muito pra gente é muito exaustivo e
agente demora muito para fazer isso a
gente perde a tempestividade várias
vezes eu coloquei essa imagem de um
ônibus escolar porque foi no meu caso me
pedindo para fazer um estudo a respeito
do transporte escolar no estado né com
os alunos da rede pública e eu fiz um
estudo muito bonito com vários dados com
várias coisas demorei um mês para fazer
só que precisava nesses dados em duas
semanas logo esse estudo não foi
utilizado e não me lembro da última vez
que ele foi utilizado é fica lá na minha
caixa no meu computador como memória
afetiva mas eu perdi nesse dilema
exaustividade vs tempestividade EA algo
que acontece sempre no governo e
provavelmente outros setores também
e o próximo aprendizado é a gente
precisa de escolher quais lutas que que
a gente vai lutar né eu fui apresentada
a várias lutas nessa luta de utilizar
dado e organizar dados de registrar o
conhecimento de aproveitar políticas
públicas passadas ao invés da gente
ficar reinventando a roda só que nem
sempre dá para você vencer todas essas
lutas e nem sempre dá para comprar todas
essas lutas quem Tenta comprar todas as
lutas como eu no início pode corre risco
de ficar extremamente decepcionado e
exaurido eu vou ver nenhum lugar difícil
para os idealistas então é é muito
importante que a gente é escolha Quais
são as batalhas que efetivamente a gente
vai lutar e qual o que que eu vou fazer
com o espaço que eu estou ocupando essa
essa é a grande essa grande Pergunta que
que eu vou fazer com os recursos que eu
tenho com espaço que o ocupa
E eu coloquei a Kitty políticas públicas
baseadas em evidência né hoje em dia a
gente tem falado muito sobre políticas
públicas baseadas em evidência e essa é
a maneira de transformar o governo tem
se falado muito disso mas por que que as
evidências não bastam apenas as
evidências por si só não bastam porque
muitas vezes as evidências os dados as
informações elas são distorcidas ou até
aproveitadas para as finalidades que que
os tomadores de decisão o que as pessoas
envolvidas tem um dado uma informação
pode servir a quem ela quiser já o
conhecimento ele é mais resiliente
contra as nossas palavras do dia a dia e
o que eu tô chamando de conhecimento
conhecimento como evidências processadas
absorvidas e refletidas mais as
experiências apenas dados e informações
elas eles não são suficientes para poder
transformar né A forma como a gente faz
política pública porque tem algo que
às vezes fora dessa equação que são as
experiências passadas e algo que a gente
perde recorrentemente dentro do governo
mas existe saída para todos esses
desafios né existem formas de promover
mudanças e eu com mais algo várias
pessoas competentíssimos dentro do
governo podemos deixar um pouco aí do
nossa marca e até hoje estamos aí nessa
luta para promover e disseminar uma
cultura de dados de conhecimento dentro
do governo a primeira uma coisa que a
gente notou quando a gente quando eu EA
minha equipe não é quando as pessoas que
trabalhavam comigo quando a gente
começou a desenvolver esse trabalho com
dados e informações a gente reparou que
a formação de servidores públicos para
análise de dados era muito deficitária
muito servidores públicos não tinham a
competências em análise de dados
ferramentas e foi aí que a gente começou
a correr atrás desse conhecimento das
aperfeiçoar e a gente viu como que saber
ferramentas pelo conhecimento pode
e foi aí que a gente criou a comunidade
igual a VR toma comunidade que Visa
conectar servidores públicos que
utilizam do Erre que é uma linguagem de
programação para análise de dados para
melhorar o trabalho do seu dia a dia a
gente conseguiu chegar a gente descobriu
que existem várias pessoas dentro do
governo que já utilizam essa ferramenta
e já fazem um trabalho muito bacana de
análise e avaliação de políticas
públicas conseguimos fazer o nosso
primeiro evento que contou aí com com 80
pessoas e depois a gente foi crescendo
nosso Impacto chegamos aproximadamente
Ensina em 180 servidores públicos e
impactados no ano passado né Depois teve
a pandemia infelizmente a gente deu uma
gente deu uma desacelerada né e mas foi
muito importante é um aprendizado que eu
trouxe disso tudo é como o poder da rede
não poder dar a conexão entre as pessoas
que nenhuma transformação se faz sozinha
EA disseminação de conhecimento é
realmente a grande chave grande poder da
transformação dentro do governo isso
ficou muito
até a próxima iniciativa que eu também
era meu sonho poder criar e eu pude
criar junto com outras pessoas foi o
data ó fiz odeio a oficina que é uma
iniciativa para trazer formação de
servidores públicos em ciência de dados
e ajudar a servidor esses servidores que
estão fazendo algum projeto relacionado
a dados dentro do governo a gente
apresenta a gente formava né esses
servidores públicos por meio de oficinas
de workshops e trazemos esse tipo de
conhecimento para que eles possam a
melhorar a forma como eles atuam no
governo e também apoiavam os eles com
metodologias para melhorar a forma como
eles essa coisa que estavam suas ações e
projetos é desafiador construir uma
cultura de conhecimento de evidências e
de pessoas conectadas em qualquer lugar
que esteja e principalmente no governo
Mas eu acredito que com pequenos passos
a gente pode sim fazer
hoje E durante toda essa minha
trajetória eu tenho muito ainda para
aprender e para viver a coisa que nós
ficou forte para mim Clara é que o maior
de todos os erros não é não fazer nada
por achar que se faz pouco por isso é a
mensagem que eu venho trazer para todos
nós é façamos tudo que a gente puder
obrigada